here on campaign check were examining
the claims and counterclaims made on the
election trail labor says it wants to
end the north-south divide by shifting
the center of gravity of investment from
London to the north and they'll do it by
spending 150 billion pounds on a Social
Fund the capital investment in schools
hospitals housing and Social Care over
the next five years so how big is the
north/south divide and what impact might
this spending have let's look at a
couple of key measures and these are for
England only first income this map shows
median weekly household income and its
highest in the southeast 544 pounds a
week London comes next and the further
north you go the lower pay gets through
the Midlands the Northwest and finally
up to the Northeast
the light color there where it's just
447 pounds a week that's nearly 100
pounds less life expectancy follows the
same rather stark pattern men in the
southeast can live on average 80 point 6
years but you die younger the further
north you travel to live up to the
Northeast just seventy seven point nine
years now these figures are for men but
the pattern is the same for women who
live about three years longer so there
clearly is a gap but public spending
already appears to address that now this
map shows public spending per head by
region you see the darkest color there
the highest spending is London
ten thousand three hundred and twenty
three pounds spent per head but spending
in the wider southeast the pale color is
actually the lowest in the country at
just over eight thousand pound eight
thousand two hundred ninety seven pounds
at the Northeast the Northwest the West
Midlands and Yorkshire all receive more
and that perhaps reflects the need of
the population rather than the affluence
now Labour's plan involves a huge amount
of spending and building in a very short
time so is it practical there are some
practical challenges for for any
government to build infrastructure on
the scales needed but they are not
insurmountable at candy's
so it'd be doing best in skills as well
as investing infrastructure then we can
have the workforce delivers in these
projects it's not a small challenge but
it is something that can be there the
spending plan by mr. McDonald will need
to be closely targeted if it's to
overcome these historic structural
inequalities in the UK economy and it
will also need time not just to build
the promise schools hospitals and houses
and the infrastructure that will serve
them but also to see whether this
attempt at a huge fundamental economic
rebalancing can bear fruit